all right susie
hi susie uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm from
brooklyn new york brooklyn yeah and tell
me about your family growing up you had
both your parents
um my father was in and out of my life
my mom she was
in and out as well
i got into
the system when i was like four years
old
got taken away from my mom why is that
um some lady stopped the train
she saw like bruises on me
so my mom got arrested and then got
taken away were those bruises from your
mom no
never got abused growing up yeah so
i believe you're taking away from your
mom for something that she didn't do
um
they just assumed i guess you know
so they took away your child
yeah
things were different back in the 90s i
guess yeah
so you you went to where foster family
yeah so i was raised by this one lady
ernesto she's in puerto rico now she
pretty much raised me until i was 18.
yeah how would you describe your
childhood um
pretty good
yeah she
she treated me like i was her daughter
always would show me off to everyone
that was pretty cool never like said oh
this is my foster child she would always
be like this is my daughter
so you felt loved yeah that's great yeah
did you ever reunite with your
biological parents i tried um
i haven't spoken to my mom in three
years um
she called the cops on me
my mom's not like all there mentally she
suffers from bipolar
and uh
other things and your dad was in your
life i haven't heard from him
in like over seven years
so i don't know if he's dead or alive
what about what about the foster family
there was a yeah my foster mom's still
alive
you had a father there
um no it was just a just my foster mom
just yeah
and how far did you go in school
i went to college i did one year at
kingsborough
i wanted to become a chef
but then i signed myself out of foster
care and pretty much
was living
not on my own i was trying to rekindle
my relationship with my biological mom
so i was pretty much paying all the
bills and working going to school i
couldn't really handle both
so i chose to continue to work
and dropped out of college
um
after living with my mom about two years
things were kind of going
really bad so
i moved out
and
this was after she called the cops on me
yeah so
so you are currently working
as
you're a sex worker at a brothel
yeah in in
outside of las vegas yeah
how did you get introduced to this
expert
i've always known about sex work um the
first time
i got introduced to it
it's like late at night my foster mom
was sleeping and i was like going
through the channels
and she had hbo
and at the time
there was a show called cat house series
and i saw an episode and i was just like
wow
like these girls are getting paid to
like do fetishes not only sexual
services like there's so much more
to the industry
besides just you know a quickie sort of
say
you know like these ladies are selling
an experience
so that to me was pretty cool
so
at a young age i've always wanted to
kind of work in the industry
what about it
appeal to you
um
i'm going to be honest
money
yeah
because like i grew up with nothing um
you know being in foster care i didn't
have like the nicest clothes i was
always wearing like hand-me-downs in
school
and so
i just wanted to be financially secure
were you doing other types of sex work
before you came to las vegas um yeah i
started when i was like 18. i was
working in like
lap dance venues in manhattan
like underground members only and i was
doing it for like two years on and off
and then my boss was like you should do
body rubs
and i'm like oh
okay and so he kind of like
showed me a few spots that he used to go
to
and so i would apply
and i kind of got a little scared so i
didn't go through it
but then i had a friend
her mom's friend was a
street
but
walker
i hate putting labels but
she would work the streets you know
pretty much yeah and she told me about
backpage
and so she was like
you know you can do other things on
there and at the time i wasn't really
open to doing full service and she was
like you know you can do fetishes
body rubs and that's when i kind of
you know
got got deep into the industry
so you live in las vegas now are you
mainly in new york mainly in new york
you come out to las vegas just to do
this where it's legal yeah
and i work in new york too independently
yeah
so
so tell me about uh
working as a
is
it's a prostitute right
is that how you use it
i mean that seems like what it is
i would consider myself an escort
um
prostitute to me means like someone
working the street
i mean
i don't know that's just my you know
growing up that's what i think um i feel
like
what was that the lines are blurry
between you know what's it called yeah
it's always like a gray area yeah i feel
like escorting is more like a high end
like yeah
i don't look like an escort
you know
you look at a girl next door
yeah that's the look i'm trying to go
for yeah so um but yeah
so
i we have like high-end clientele it's
not like we're selling an experience
so it's it's not like a quick one to get
out
like the girls are doing in the street
you know they go into anybody's car
so you work at a brothel outside of las
vegas yeah i work at chicken ranch it's
called chicken ranch yeah
and how many girls are working there
it's a small house so like 7 to fourteen
and guys will come in any time of day
guys couples women
yep
and they'll
book a session with you for for what an
hour or something
yeah they can book an hour they can book
overnight um
yeah
what does that cost
i wish i could say i don't want to get
in trouble by the ranch but you know
it's more than it's like four figures
yeah right definitely like couple
thousand
wow yeah
so
you know the house takes
they say 50 but it's more like 60
percent because we pay rent
um on top of that like if they come in
in a cab we have to give them additional
15 on top of
the cut that we already give them
you know and then we've got to pay for
our makeup
hair
testing
you know we do std testing weekly yeah
background checks
that's
we all pay that out of pocket so
and you're treated well over there
yeah by both
the
the
brothel as well as your clients yeah
i love my clients you do yeah
they're cool people tell me about your
typical client
i see all kinds of clients i see virgins
i see couples i see women
i've had clients that
ceos
uh nypd officers
lawyers yeah
yeah
does this guy see them all yeah does
this get in the way of your
your love life your personal life yeah i
don't think you don't even have a
personal life
i i feel like the industry kind of
messed that up for me because i'm like
why would i talk to somebody for free
when i have guys paying me
and they treat me way better
so
you're conditioned to connect money with
love
[Music]
have you ever been in love
i have yeah yeah
did you have kids
i was pregnant
yeah at 18.
so you were you were pregnant did you be
yeah
and you you had the child
mm-hmm
[Music]
where do you see yourself going you're
you're still young yet
i'm 26 26 i want to retire
i can't do this forever
you're saving money i take it of course
yes
i want to get into real estate i also
want to become a foster mom
you know i want to help out
other kids that may need a home
you know
great
doing this kind of work does it affect
you emotionally
yeah
um i feel like sometimes i don't have
emotion i'm very like
i don't i don't know just very you have
to turn them off right
to do this right
yeah
do you use drugs or alcohol no too i
smoke weed
but i don't i'm not a drinker you can do
this sober
yeah
yeah when i work in the brothel i'm
sober all the time because they don't
let us smoke weed
in the house so
yeah
i mean i love the job but you know
sometimes it does get tiring you get you
know some clients that they end up
falling in love with you and then they
don't want to pay you no more
you know they want to see you for free
and it's just it's a little too much
sometimes you know
yeah it gets complicated yeah
do you think you're you're it be
possible for you to fall in love now
you've been doing this for how long now
like
six six years six years seven well
dancing is sex work so yeah a little bit
longer because it would be difficult for
you to meet a guy
that's that's not involved in any of
this kind of stuff
and he's for him to accept that you do
it would be difficult for him i would
think
when i first started i was i was dating
the love of my life my first love
but um
it was difficult for him
so it's like i don't know i may be
single for the rest of my life who knows
i don't know
do you feel like you're missing out on
something by by choosing this career
no
not really you know um
from a young age i've always wanted like
greater for myself i didn't want to be
another statistic you know being in
foster care
having kids struggling
you know like
at least i'm financially like stable
did you grow up fairly
poor
i mean my foster mother wasn't rich yeah
no she wasn't working she was just
depending on the checks that acs was
sending her money yeah sorry i wonder if
the desire is to be financially stable
just kind of got you into this
yeah you think that was a factor
yeah yeah
i think it's a factor for a lot of the
girls that do this kind of
money is what drives them
of course yeah
but then you get some clients too where
it's like it's rewarding because then
like for for example the other day um
i had saw a client
and he came in with his wife
and she couldn't perform
you know any
sexual yeah
and
he you know told me what happened and
everything he ended up booking me we did
the session
and he started crying to me like that
kind of like i started to cry
you know
because it's like it's more than just
you're selling an experience you're
selling
i don't it sounds like you're almost a
therapist yeah pretty much a therapist
yeah
so
and that one that's what makes me like
love the job that i do because i'm like
damn i'm
i'm helping you're healing people yeah
like i'm not trying to homewreck i'm not
trying to take your man
i don't want you man
you know i'm just here to do a job
so
yeah
you can see this as you're doing a good
deed
pretty much
i feel like i have a lot of love in me
though even though i'm
sometimes uh i feel like i'm cold you
stand fish
but because of
i never had that like
affection growing up like my foster
mother was always nice to me but she
never like hugged me or kissed me you
know
so
we're getting deep mark yeah that's what
i do yeah
really
what do you think you missed most in
your childhood
in a sense just just being a child again
yeah
i was such in a rush to grow up
really yeah i just wonder if there's
something
that led you into this at this this line
of work that
happened in your childhood
i never
i never got molested never been
so i
i just came across that hbo
it stuck to me and then in middle school
i came across the girls next door
on vh1 and that kind of like
opened up my eyes
to the industry and
just always wanted to be a part of the
industry
what's your favorite type of uh quiet
all my clients are my favorite you like
them all i like them all
i love them all equally
i get a lot of jewish clients so
yeah
yeah
are a lot of your clients married
yeah
a lot of them are married what do you
what do you think of
monogamy for humans do you think we're
meant to be monogamous or
i think everybody cheats
yeah
do you think prostitution should be
legalized
i think so
you know it's legal where you're working
in vegas and in new york they just kind
of changed they decriminalized it yeah
they decriminalized it yeah i work from
home in new york i know that sounds
crazy but
i do my proper screening you know i
asked him for a deposit
so is it weird bringing strangers into
your house into my home yeah but i have
cameras in like the entryway
have you ever had bad things happen
never never
because i do the proper screening yeah
not like this not like the girls that
work the streets
yeah that's that's different i've never
worked the streets
that's yeah
are there drugs involved with your
clients
um i have some clients that come in and
like to party yeah but i don't i don't
do drugs at all
just
just marijuana
yeah
do you recall your very first time
having sex for money
um
wow i was 23
i was single
because when i first started working in
the industry i wasn't doing full service
because i was with my significant other
[Music]
but yes i do remember
i
was working at a different ranch
i'm not going to mention the name but it
was like up north
and i had booked somebody for 12 000.
yeah
so that was like pretty cool i was like
wow
that's a lot of money
are you lonely
yeah
i get lonely
you get lonely
despite the fact that how many
companions you have
yeah i'm not always busy though
you know
i don't see everybody every day you know
so
how many nights a week will you work
differently
i mean i'm open like 24 7. like i'll see
some clients at like 5 00 a.m at my
place and same at the ranch too like
we're open 24 7. um
but you know we don't get booked every
single day so
there are days where you know i don't
see anybody for two or three days
but then that fourth day i'm like super
busy
right just random
how does doing this work impact your
self-esteem
um
a little bit
i would say does it build it up or
underneath it builds it up did you ever
feel like a just an object
just no because all my clients treat me
like like i'm a goddess like
they all respect me
you know they're all very nice um
growing up i was uh
very insecure
so
it's pretty cool to have someone like
pay you
for
for your looks but not only your looks
but your personality too because you can
i know some girls that work in the
industry and they are gorgeous they have
work done
you know but their personality sucks
and then they wonder why that client
doesn't come back right so
yeah personality's gonna be a big part
of it yeah
what's the hardest part of doing this
kind of work
for you
there's really no
no hard part for me no it's easy for me
honestly yeah
[Music]
how do you think being a sex worker has
changed you
um i'm very business oriented though yes
you are yes
yes you're a money maker yeah
so
[Music]
dear friends
i do
i've lost a lot of friends and family
because because of this career yeah
yeah
do you think do you think americans are
uptight about sex
i don't know why
everybody has sex
yeah i know but you know every everybody
has you know their little side pieces so
i don't know a lot of people freak out
or nudity and sex and
i don't know why
you know
it's a beautiful thing who doesn't love
sex
you know times have changed
is there is it can any girl do this kind
of work or do you have to be a certain i
don't think any girl could do this kind
of work what personality traits help you
to do this you just have to be very uh
personable like you got to really
enjoy your job
you know like or know how to fake it you
know like
smile with your clients you know just
you gotta charm them yeah you gotta
charm them
what advice would you give to a young
woman who's thinking of doing this kind
of work
make sure that this is something you
know you really want to do because
some girls make it look easy but it's
hard work
you know
[Music]
is there a lot of competition with the
other girls at the brothel
like how does it work a guy walks in and
you're all just sitting there yeah you
stand up and
no no no so um he'll go to the bar
and be like you know i want to do a
lineup and so they'll call for all the
girls to do a lineup we'll each come out
separately you know introduce ourselves
and then he'll pick the girl that he
wants
and then yeah that's pretty much it the
girl will take him to the room negotiate
a price
and that's pretty much it
yeah
but there's no competition like all the
girls are pretty nice where i work at
yeah yeah they are not catty at all so
that's cool it's nice yeah
it feels more like a family because it's
a lot of uh girls have been working
there
for a couple years so it's a lot of the
same faces yeah what have you learned
about men doing this kind of work
that they all cheat
no not every man
cheats but most of them do
you know um
not only with men but with women i feel
like we all need intimacy
i feel like
we all lack
that i don't know if i said it right but
that's one thing i learned about the
industry like we all
need love
so
just
and does this
suffice in your life as love what you do
um
oh gosh mark you're killing me here with
discussions
um you know what i do
somewhat i would say
you know i mean
damn how do i don't know
see i don't want to say something and
then it comes off like you know bad cold
because like yeah
you know like i'm very loving but also i
am selling a service yeah i i might i
suspect that you might be a cold hard
businesswoman making money
cleaning
claiming that this is what's good enough
for you and this is all you want
but the right guy could walk into your
life and change all that
maybe i suspect
you just haven't met him yet where's he
at
you definitely have to be street smart
though too to work in this industry even
if you want to like work independently
or in a brothel like why is that
um
i would say more so independently um
it takes a lot you got to screen them
you know um
how do you screen i'm about to teach
some free free game right now um so i
advertise on like multiple sites um one
of them is like rub ratings
tris or arrows i'm pretty sure some of
the people are familiar with that
website
um and then they'll call me
and then i'll be like you know send me a
selfie with you holding up the peace
sign by your face and like a picture of
your id
um
most of the time when they send you that
they're not going to try nothing stupid
in your apartment because you already
have their identification
you know like i will call the cops if
you assault me in my apartment i will
call the cops yeah i'm a sex worker
is the criminalizing new york like
this man assault assaulted me like it's
a smart way to protect yourself yeah
so
that's how i do my screening
and
it's interesting do you have any regrets
in your life
no
i don't
i don't um
to go back to the uh
the abortion
um
i've had
after i had the abortion at 18 um
i regretted it for a while
but now that i'm like much older i'm
like i'm kind of
thankful that i went through with that
because that would be selfish of me to
keep a baby and i'm struggling
and it's like history replaying itself
so
you know i don't i don't regret
anything
what was the best time of your life
best time of my life
wow um
just
this yeah right now pretty much that's
great yeah
what was the best example you had of a
loving relationship
when you were a child growing up
did you see anything like in your mom
or friends parents
not i mean my foster mom was always by
herself there was never a man around
um
i ended up finding later that he was
like arrested
um
but i've never she
stood by him she never had men around
the house
took care of me and my other siblings
so
i guess that would be love right she
doesn't have to do that
yeah right
and what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
the most important thing
never to hold grudges
yeah
even though me and my mom you know i
haven't spoken to her
i forgive her i love her
but i'm just going to keep my distance
forgiveness is important
[Music]
all right susie thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
thank you thank you very much
you